our top story this hour millions of
people have fled ukraine since the start
of the russian invasion there the
majority an estimated 1.8 million have
found refuge in neighboring poland and
some are dealing not only with the
trauma of war but with a crisis that can
strike a family at any time a serious
health condition affecting a child
hundreds of young patients have made the
dangerous trip out of their war-torn
country to poland where they're now
fighting a different battle
christina raffini has the story from
poland's border with ukraine
on the other side of this border a
rescue is in progress
two critical pediatric patients driven
by civilian volunteers overnight from
levee to warsaw thirteen-year-old kiro
was rushed into the operating room hours
after arrival it was his 36th surgery
how many kids do you have on the sport
normally we can admit about
19 children dr radhik jaber is the head
of pediatric oncology and hematology at
the medical university in geshef about
an hour from the ukrainian border in
addition to polish patients they're
treating eight children evacuated from
ukraine most of them cancer patients or
a cancer and with serious hematologic
hematological
diseases like civil anemia plastic etc
okay so very serious things to have the
best chance at recovery doctors say it's
paramount that seriously ill patients
not have their treatment disrupted
but in a war zone nothing is guaranteed
so st jude's children's research
hospital based in memphis partnered with
hospitals and doctors all over europe to
get the most vulnerable out so far 28
countries and more than 201 clinics
across the world are offering support
for these young patients yaroslava has
acute leukemia she was transported from
ukraine and on her way to ireland when
she developed a serious infection were
you worried she wouldn't get her
treatment when you had to leave
yes she says they also had no place to
go but since arriving in poland
garasalava has gotten the treatment she
needs and the family including her two
young siblings has been allowed to live
in her hospital room until she's ready
to be moved these children from ukraine
[Music]
might not be treated not be cured
without
treatment outside ukraine and
probably the the
big part of them
would i probably so you're saying if
for these cancer patients to survive now
you think they probably need to be
treated outside ukraine or or they may
not survive
yes so we have to do everything every
patient from
ukraine
should be
a
possibility to be treated
somewhere outside doctors working with
these patients say about 400 children
have been evacuated from ukraine since
the start of the conflict with about a
hundred and fifty more expected to
arrive this week for cbs saturday
morning christina raffini zeschaf poland
so incredible the work that saint jude's
does they see about 8 600
children every year add these
you know and what they're doing to help
and support
uh the patients in poland it's
heartbreaking to see these kids who
already are fighting the battle of their
lives then have to move and not be able
to get the treatment they should get
it's crisis after crisis yep